everyone we're getting our top eight
underway and it's going to be super
akuma versus tatsu germany
versus france here these guys have
history these guys have history right
tetsu was the one that put super creamer
into the loser bracket at evo not too
long ago so i know that super akuma you
know he he's he's gonna be taking this
one seriously here sam yeah definitely
and i mean as we were talking about at
the very start you said it to me that a
lot of these players practice against
super akuma's akuma specifically and
very jump heavy very cross-up set up
oaky heavy um akuma that uh superkuma
loves to play so let's see what tetsu
can do with that jump forward job
awkward and yeah
absolutely man i mean so you've got the
blue hands available see if you can do
something with that of course claudia a
very strong character the one why not
the punish
great whip punish there super groom is
definitely going to be thinking more
about throwing out those fireballs and
you can't just uh control the space with
them anymore you need to make sure that
the player is at a perfect range that
you can't get punished like that for
sure yeah the blue hand is still
available head to starburst tries to use
their massive whiff super camera good
punish rage available now here we go
just
luke's stuff into the stair down i like
it i like it yeah so dominance eight
seconds left on the clock somebody's
gonna have to do something tattooed
behind oh wait a minute five seconds
left wonder woman into it and a down
watch your toes man that's super akuma
in front of you
yeah and the super kim also says as well
the reason why he uses so much of the
down for the sweep is because it's got
it's a move which has a lot of tracking
it will track if you side walk left or
right so he uses it to try and stop his
opponent from sidestepping as we see the
focus attack there look at superhumans
doing super cool stuff here two bars i'm
here to work with as well this is
looking bad for jesse
and the crossovers again man
that's the super akuma that uh we saw
winning all sorts of offline events back
in the day he's he's back ladies and
gentlemen and he is not going anywhere
did you see that last rounds back yeah i
mean tetsu had the life he died looking
really good for him but then super came
up it only takes one yeah oh really only
especially when you have two bars of
mirror give us a highlight reel now
super camera go on here with that little
down poke do it down three i know you
want to do it i know you want to do it
do it
all right nice
oh we tried it he tried
the running down three classic classic
akuma strats
he's waiting for rage i feel like that's
what he wants he wants that bonus damage
so they thinking hundred to zero very
quickly
he is now two bars and rage left
yeah it does carry on over into the next
one
oh no is he dead
i think he's dead guys i think it's over
the crowd oh it doesn't work yeah he
delayed the sexual there a little bit i
think from tetsu
massive lively for super crema though
yes sir
he ran both of his bars though in that
last combo here interruptions here from
tatsu
getting a big wall stuff
oh nice holding four but there was not a
shout right there tattoo answering back
two-two final round and akuma is maybe
only gonna have one bar of meter but if
he keeps whiffing like that
yeah hey there's the bar let's see what
he can do with it oh nice punish holy
cow super akuma now we'll be able to
take this to the wall tatsu dangerous
situation now with the bar mitzvah super
cool
okay we're gonna see some uh janky open
stuff not just yet
but half like left on tattoo hot kick
gets them out
okay
good punish
oh this is so close test time this is so
close one bar me a half of super cube to
work with final round down four now the
lows
oh it works but i think he's building up
another bar for himself it should be
about two fireballs to get it here oh
big with oh just outside the range as
well a great position to have him in
here
launched okay punish there's the two
bars
oh
oh burns one there oh god oh no it
doesn't work four seconds left oh my god
with the comeback right at the end what
a close first game
oh my god oh my god
we knew it was going to be pumped back
when we saw that match coming up we knew
it was gonna be pumped whoo all right
tattoo tattoo taking that taken up by
the skin of his teeth four seconds left
on the clock and he burns the blue stuff
that was impressive that was impressive
and usually super cooler is the one that
kind of comes out on top in those
scramble situations but this time tetsu
did you see the punish on the fireball
this is not something that happens you
know fireball is -14 not many people
know about this and at certain ranges
you can punish it very easily depending
on what character you're using we
haven't seen super akuma in many
tournaments this year get punished for
using fireball tetsu says you know what
shut up get that [ __ ] out of here man
back to you punish the fireball and the
beautiful come up with the rage ride
yeah that was just i mean
it shows that tattoo has practiced and
practiced and practiced this particular
match up because that's not something
you accidentally work out you know and
he did the running two to punish the
fireball in round one there just to show
him he said yeah i dare you throw it out
again i better be really far away the
next time you throw that like you know
but super akuma is a
high highly ranked player so uh let's
see what we can do we're going to howard
estate now super akuma's pick
yeah of course we're going to have a
look at that staging the howard estate
is the stage that a lot of the 2d
players will go to
because the breakable walls give um
these these certain characters a lot of
damage right and it's not only the two
these a lot of
other characters as well will benefit
off using the stage let's see if super
kuma can even this one out yeah let's
see
i've seen a little bit more aggression
coming out but wow you can't get away
with that that's tattoo in front of you
bro
this is the wall here and he's got the
sparkle fish to to play around with just
lost it there
yeah it is back to the breakable he
tried a hopkick right there he wants to
end this quick man
yeah a lot of damage there
oh my god are you serious is it that
great
no rain
yeah nice oh my god tetsu
tattoo big obstacle potential right now
the thing is sam that super creamer puts
you into this scramble situation so many
times i don't even know what's going on
here man at the moment this is crazy
well ted suit seems to know exactly
what's going on and he is using these
scrambles to his advantage which is not
something super kuma is used to dealing
with so he's coming out on top a lot
here
yeah and staying just outside of course
if you want to get the big combo from
the down three it has to be in clean hit
range which is it has to be very very
close to you tetsu spacing very well but
the nice punishment with a jab into dp
we're in the corner now big damage there
off the hop kick punish oh man guess
where you're like punish that yes sir
tattoo answering back here oh another
weird oaky stuff
oh no okay looking for the beyblade
yeah good stuff there superkima you know
he just decided to go for the 5050s at
the wall down three into the mid oh try
to punch down two but just out of range
tetsu
you can see sam he's on point right oh
man yeah he's ready he's ready for this
match man
okay big launcher here for akuma the
touch of death
down okay
i'm forcing him to guess here
yep
charging up here no duck there what a
float that's exactly what you need to do
against nakuma if he's jumping in your
face just send that jabba send it out
get that
wonder woman it's getting pressure here
whoa
didn't let it rip unfortunately just a
little bit of a
miscommunication between superkuma's
brain and his fingers but 15 seconds
left on the clock tetsu does not look
like he's uh he's coming back from
listening wait a minute
oh
oh could a rage are there i don't know
what he didn't
know
yeah that was not a i don't know why he
didn't rage out after the wall break it
would have stopped the clock and put him
in there
in a lively situation there yeah i don't
think he was looking at the clock there
until the end and that is why you don't
always jab versus the demon flip because
the the dive kick will beat the jab and
get you launched pretty cheap putts oh
good stuff different super humor
yep
tattoo working on a light deficit now
here
okay poking away trying to catch his
lead back here charlie not known for
having really good lows but he's uh
showing us how to use him here
okay
big big with no punish test dude the
whiff punishment already on point here
super humor working his way back and he
has the life here and a bar me to work
with
yeah
25 seconds left on the clock here
using cars really effectively tatsu just
outside of rage now this is exactly
where super tacoma wants him
oh
big half kick with
boost off
okay are we making it to the fire wall
yes we are we're gonna no wait no way
oh the dp
get
the it frames did not kick in and here
we go now final round here tatsu is he
gonna give him to take it
i mean if he does uh all bets are off
the table ladies and gentlemen this is
super akuma fighting for his winners
bracket life it's best the trees so this
is is oh wait a minute there we go big
barber here already working oh no but a
drop super akuma's feeling them jitters
and all two human chill runs down this
god spine
here we go
tessa can you make another comeback he
hasn't got starburst or rage available
there it is now okay
that sparkled face just outside the rage
again we've seen this rerun from the
last one there's the rage gets the child
okay wonder woman
working on sparklefish 16 seconds left
on the clock watch it because it's going
to play a huge role beyblade not good
watch oh my god this is going to be it
is is gonna take it over super kimmer
200.
once again
what
i don't get
i don't get it zero and two super
akuma's down in the losers bracket now
yeah
crazy stuff man that's an upset that's
an upset right now i mean tattoo is a
great player we just saw it there but i
don't think anybody had money on that
one
yeah i mean again you know we said we
said it before the match that tetsu did
put super camera into the loser bracket
in uh evo you know that was a match that
that worked in tetsu's favor and let's
have a look at somebody